this is Kevin from the chess website
calm today we're going to be looking at
another in-game scenario that deals with
the bishop and Knight this is probably
one of the most difficult in games that
you'll come across it's not too common
but it's all definitely one of the in
games that you'll want to know how to do
it's very good to study just to know how
the bishop in the knight work together
as well keep in mind while we go over
this video no endgame is going to be
exactly the same so while I'm going to
give you specific moves
don't try necessarily to memorize the
moves instead try to understand
conceptually what I'm doing and how the
pieces move together so that when you do
play if your opponent moves correctly or
incorrectly you'll be able to take
advantage and checkmate the black King
with under 50 moves if the moves does
reach 50 it's actually a drawing game so
you need to know how to do it pretty
quickly so we're going to go ahead and
get started here and go over some key
concepts now the first thing we want to
look at is this bishop it's a dark
squared Bishop and that means that
eventually the only way to checkmate the
King is if we can get the King down to
one of these corners you do the h8 or
the a1 corner we can check made him on
the a1 or the b1 square but he's going
to have to come to one of these corners
as black he's going to try to spend all
his time on the opposite corners so keep
that in mind another key concept you'll
see is we don't check the King very much
until the very end we're actually just
trying to surround the King force him to
go a specific way kind of block off his
moves from retreating from us and then
at the very end we will launch our
attack on him so the worst thing you can
do is just try to check the King as much
as you can
it's really not going to do you any good
so obviously in any end game you want to
activate your king early and often and
use him because he can make a blockade
pretty much anywhere he is against the
opponent's king so we're going to go
ahead and take a look at this position
and first thing we're going to do is our
King is way away from where we want them
to be so we're going to go ahead and
activate our King here we're going to go
ahead and move him to e2 and black King
is going to move to d7 doesn't really
matter right now where he goes he's just
trying to run around and have a
draw-game after 50 moves we're going to
go and continue up the board with our
King get him more active black is going
to move c6 and we're going to continue
just chasing after him to d4 and what
black can continue to move now black
obviously does not want to move towards
a 1 he's going to checkmate himself a
lot faster than he wants to so if he
plays correctly as you should if you are
defending you're eventually going to
want to come to the a 8 square then if
you can dance around back to the h1
square but if he starts coming to the a1
square you'll see with some of the
concepts were going over he can lose
very quickly so more than likely he's
going to go the other way but first
we're going to go ahead and activate our
knight here we've already got our King
into the mix and so our night was over
here wasn't doing anything so we're
going to go and bring them into the game
doesn't really matter which one which
way you bring him into the game but
we're going to bring them to the e3
Square and blacks going to go ahead and
continue up here to the corner where we
can't checkmate him but that's ok we'll
we'll eventually deal with him so he
goes to b6 and we're going to go ahead
and start to bring our King up the board
eventually we want to get our our King
to this c6 square so faster we can get
to the c6 square the better
black like I said before is going to
continue up the board here and now our
bishops starting to get out of the
action so we're going to go ahead and
bring our bishop into the action and
we're going to start taking away some
squares these blue squares are purple
our scores that he can't go to so he's
got to move somewhere else he can't
dance around this way it doesn't really
matter which died or excuse me
column he goes if he goes towards this
8h square or the a1 square it doesn't
really matter we're just trying to get
our Bishop active here
let's see where black goes black goes to
b6 so that is not a problem at all we're
going to go ahead and activate our
knight little closer into the game so
he's in the action and this is a check
even though it's it's not a check to
make the King move it's a check just to
get the knight into the action here so
that is why that move was made and the
black is going to retreat to his a eight
corner and we're going to start to move
our pieces a little farther we're going
to go ahead and move our King a little
closer to the action so he can't come
down and you've already started to see
that we've started to block off some
squares for black our knight is blocking
off some squares we have our Bishop
activated and so we've started already
on only our eighth move
we've already
brought about a very good position and
so we're going to go ahead and continue
here block is going to go ahead and just
move back he right now is in no serious
threat he's in the a eight corner and
now our king is on the C six squared and
obviously on other sides of the board
it's going to be different but in this
case the C six square is a very crucial
spot for the king at the beginning now
depending on where the black King goes
it can change but very crucial Square
and you can already see that we've
started to block off a lot of different
squares the black Keene can only go to a
eight and a six now so he's going to go
ahead and go to the eight squares
trusted square and we're going to go
ahead and bring our Knight to b6 and I
got a lot of visuals up here you really
want to I find it the easiest way is to
have your your King on c6 or this square
wherever it is on the board c3 or f3 or
f6 and you want to have your knight
right next to them it's a little easier
to maneuver as you can see we eventually
want to just March this king all the way
down to the a1 square that is the best
square that we can get into and we don't
want him if we have our night here on b6
we want to bring them here if we add our
knight on c6 we'd want to bring them to
the h8 square but since we want to bring
them down here we have our Bishop
nightly nicely positioned on the e5
square attacking the b8 square so the
King cannot come here he can't come to
the b7 square because of our King and so
he's going to have to march down this
file right here and we're going to show
you how to do that so as you can see his
only move is a 7 so he's going to go
ahead and move there
and now we don't want the King to come
back here our Knight and King are nicely
placed right now so we're just going to
go ahead and improve our bishop for a
second and we're going to go ahead and
move him to c7 it's kind of the same
setup as before he can pretty much move
to the same squares he can't go back to
the AAA because of our Knights who's
going to have to continue marching down
the board here like we wanted to and now
we want to stop him from retreating back
to the eight square and we have our
knight in key nicely placed we're
actually going to move our bishop and
block off this a7 square so his only
move is the a5 square as you can see we
forced pretty much every move all the
way down this file so far so King has to
move to a5 which he does and now a very
important move one that if you haven't
studied this in game it's going to be
pretty tough for you to catch and we
actually from here want to activate our
knight and get him into the action our
Bishop is keeping him from coming back
but we want we do not want the King to
make his way down to the h1 square and
so we're going to block off some squares
with our knight and that's going to be
Knight to d5 like I said before we don't
want him to get to the h1 square and
this subtle move right here blocks off
some of the squares that the King can go
to the Knights blocking off this b4 and
c3 and the King has this b5 blocked off
so
he is going to have to have a longer
track to the h1 square so we're going to
go ahead and follow black King goes a
four and we're going to go ahead and
continue down with our King give a
better position for our King and the c5
square is actually the outpost for our
King for a while he is going to